Maxwell is with us in Maryland hi
Maxwell welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks for having me Dave sure what's up
hey so basically I'm about 25,000 and
debts from my student loans and
everything like that and I had a app
idea that I have about fifty five
percent funded right now and I have to
come up with thirty thousand to invent
it and get it all made and everything
like that so I just kind of wanted your
input whether I should kind of tackle
the debt or go after the ass your
programmer know so the company that's
making it is actually you know saying
hey we need seventy thousand to make it
they invent they invested forty thousand
into it and I just have to come up with
the extra thirty they already have
invested yes oh no well they're it's
based off of if I can get that thirty
percent I'm sorry there's any work been
done no no no it's it's all it's you
know when it's the investor which is me
or another investor puts that 30 K up
and they put up where did you turn these
people cubics it's a pretty well-known
math developer okay
I suspect you could hire someone to
write an app for the money you've got I
mean I've got guys sitting here all day
long right naps at our place so um and
yet you're not even going to home this
thing a hundred percent when you're done
with this right you're just getting a
piece of it
yeah no I'll have eighty percent
ownership yeah
after having I listen I want you to
investigate different ways to do this I
think you can do this cheaper than
you're talking about um I'm a little
shocked at the price tag to develop an
app I don't know I don't know how
complicated this app is but you
understand too when you're developing an
app you're talking about putting it on
iTunes and then you're gonna try to
monetize it at whatever rate right I
mean you're gonna try to make your money
back
yep yeah and you understand there's a
roll of the dice
mm-hmm I do I really think it's a kind
of a one-of-a-kind
monetised yeah of course you think then
go into it if you didn't think that
but dude all the stuff that I you know
all the stuff that I have tried that
hasn't worked I can promise you some of
the things I think are gonna work and
I'm pretty smart don't work mmm
so it might work I'm not saying it don't
work but I I think you need to figure
out other ways skin this cat huh I'm
gonna pay cash for this and I want you
to get out of debt to what do you make a
year all about fifty thousand right now
okay I don't think I can stop you
because I think you're already on the
bench doing this so but I think the
money you have laying there you probably
get this app developed if you found a
couple good developers and maybe give
them a couple of points of ownership in
it if it took off and in order to
discount their rate instead of trying to
go with this out of the box deal that
you're messing with here I'm I wouldn't
do the deal you're doing IIIi smell I
smell overpriced that's what I smell
because we do apps around here all the
time
and and once that have made lots of
money I got five million people on every
dollar and we got a lot more money in
the seventy grand and every dollar but a
whole lot more than that in it but now I
think you pay cash for it and you own it
and you take your business risk that way
that's what I would do or get yourself
out of debt and then when you're out of
debt save up the money and then do it
but I don't think I can stop you I think
you're already on your track